I know 6 is the same thing as 2 times 3, and 9 is the same thing as 3 times 3. I
can reduce an equivalent of 1. 3 divided by 3 makes 1. So I have 2/3. So let's
see, 2/3, that would be e. Alright, for 4 and 12, I know 4 goes into 4 and 4
goes into 12. So I'm going to have 4 times 1 and 4 times 3. Here, I have 4
divided by 4. I know these are factors that appear in both the numerator and the
denominator so I can reduce these to 1. 1 times 1 is 1, 1 times 3 is 3, so 1/3.
Let's see, 1/3 would be d. For 9/15, I divide 9 and 15 by 3. So, I know 9 is the
same thing as 3 times 3, 15 is 3 times 5. Again, I have an equivalent of 1, 3
divided by 3 makes 1. So, I'm left with 3/5. 3/5 would be answer choice c, I
have 3 pieces out of 5. For 10/12, I'm going to divide them both by 2. I know 10
divided by 2 is 5, and 12 divided by 2 is 6. I didn't show the work here, but I
was just factoring out 2 over 2. So, I get answer choice b, I have 5 out of 6
pieces. For 9/12, I'm going to write 9 as 3 times 3, and 12 as 3 times 4. Again,
I have the 3 divided by 3 which makes 1, so I get 3/4. 3/4 would be f. And
finally, I have 8 divided by 24. This one might have been a little trickey. I
can think of 8 as 2 times 4, and 24 as 6 times 4. Notice, I have 4 divided by 4,
so I can cancel those to make 1, and then I have 2 times 1, which is 2. And 6
times 1, which is 6. 2, 6. But I can still simplify this fraction. I know 2 can
be written as 2 times 1, and 6 can be written as 2 times 3. 2 divided by 2 makes
1, so I get 1/3. Hmm, that seemed like a lot of math. I could've probably gotten
to this answer quicker. I know my answer choice should be d, but let's see how I
could have done it faster. You notice how I canceled a 4 over 4 and a 2 over 2.
Well, really, that would have been the same thing as 4 times 2 which is 8, and
the 4 times 2 which is 8. I would have had an 8 in the numerator and an 8 in the
denominator. Let me show you what that would have looked like. I would have
written 8 as 1 times 8, a nd 24 as 3 times 8. Notice 8 divided by 8 makes 1,
because there are common factors in the numerator and denominator. And I have 1
over 3, or 1/3. Notice, if I take out the largest number in both the numerator
and the denominator, I get to my answer more quickly. Usually, that's what we
want to do when we simplify. That's why it's helpful to know factors of a
number.